LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance
présente état de santé
[Musique]
en matière d'activité physique les
scientifiques sont sûrs d'une chose on
sait que l'activité physique c'est bon
pour la santé mais à condition d'en
faire régulièrement et c'est loin d'être
le cas 95% des Français n'en feraient
pas assez même les enfants
il y a 20 ans puisqu'on a gardé des
statistiques et performances du groupe
correspondaient à peu près aux
performances des meilleures
d'aujourd'hui alors comment s'y mettre
ou s'y remettre comment encourager le
sport santé sport le meilleur des
remèdes c'est le thème de ce numéro
d'état de santé
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans cet état de
santé aujourd'hui on va parler du sport
et de la santé on a tous bien compris
que le sport c'est bon pour la santé et
bien c'est contre-intuitif mais
globalement mondialement et bien on fait
moins d'exercices physiques que dans les
années 70 pourtant on le sait le sport
c'est un médicament qui prévient jusqu'à
certaines maladies graves et puis quand
on fait du sport et ben on vieillit
mieux bonjour Martin Fourcade on est
très honoré de vous recevoir vous êtes
le biathlète quintuple champion
olympique vous allez nous dire vous êtes
tombé dedans tout petit mais peut-être
que c'était pas si naturel pour vous
finalement aussi mais d'abord on regarde
votre portrait
[Musique]
Martin Fourcade est un biathlète
français quand tu peux champion
olympique considéré comme l'un des
meilleurs biathlètes de l'histoire il
est le seul à avoir remporté 7 fois le
classement général de la Coupe du monde
sportif français le plus titré des Jeux
Olympiques il a raccroché ses skis en
2020 en annonçant sa retraite de
biathlète à 32 ans mais la passion du
sport ne l'a pas quitté et il utilise à
présent quotidien sa notoriété pour
promouvoir et défendre les valeurs du
sport ambassadeur MGEN il préside la
commission des athlètes des JO 2024 et
il est membre du CIO l'un de ses
nouveaux défis encourager la pratique
sportive et promouvoir le sport santé
[Musique]
Martin Fourcade encore une fois on est
très très content de vous avoir
aujourd'hui dans cet état de santé vous
quand vous avez commencé le sport bon
c'était une pratique familiale moi ce
qui est assez rigolo c'est que j'ai
finalement j'ai fait du sport tout mon
enfance en m'en rendre compte j'ai eu la
chance et j'estime que c'est une énorme
chance de de grandir dans un
environnement assez naturel assez assez
privilégié et du coup on joue dehors on
passe nos journées dans les bois dans
les arbres à pratiquer une activité
physique en fait toujours parce que là
c'est fini les compétitions officielles
on verra plus Championnat du Monde etc
mais ça reste pour vous une obligation
chaque jour de faire du sport oui ce qui
est assez rigolo c'est que j'étais en
compétiteur acharné pendant ma carrière
et en arrêtant ma carrière en 2020 cet
aspect de compétiteur c'est presque
totalement effacé par contre la pratique
sportive et le fait de faire du sport
reste un élément central dans ma vie
j'en ai besoin déjà d'un point de vue
corporel pour me sentir bien j'en ai
besoin d'un point de vue social pour
pratiquer le sport avec mes amis pendant
20 ans j'ai créé des relations grâce au
sport et avec le sport aujourd'hui si
j'arrête le sport je n'ai plus d'amis je
vais les voir sur un vélo je pars en
montagne ce qui est avec eux je voilà
donc c'est aussi un lien social qui est
pour moi primordial et enfin c'est c'est
une manière de transmettre j'ai des
petites filles aujourd'hui deux petites
filles qui ont 5 et 7 ans et là où je
m'épanouis le plus avec elle c'est quand
je suis en mesure de pouvoir les
accompagner en montagne cette manière de
pouvoir transmettre à mes enfants à
travers la pratique sportive de pouvoir
partager avec elle c'est quelque chose
qui pour moi aussi est primordial dans
ma vie de famille on en parlera tout à
l'heure des enfants évidemment c'est
fondamental quand on parle du sport
alors une question qu'on doit vous poser
tout le temps
il y a des gens qui font pas de sport
parce que c'est un effort c'est un
effort il faut s'y mettre etc vous savez
ce que ça vous demande un effort vous le
faire du sport alors moi c'est une
demande un effort il y a des jours où
j'ai pas envie d'y aller mais vraiment
vraiment la motivation c'est pas quelque
chose qui est inné c'est quelque chose
qui se crée qui se génère au quotidien
qui s'entretient et j'arrive aussi à
trouver du plaisir dans cet effort c'est
un plaisir c'est un médicament c'est un
bien fait le sport à quel point et
pourquoi on regarde cette infographie
[Musique]
pourquoi l'activité physique est-elle
bonne pour la santé parce qu'elle agit
sur l'ensemble du corps et des organes
regardez le système cardio-respiratoire
en bougeant l'activité des muscles
augmente ils ont besoin de plus
d'oxygène et les poumons travaillent en
accélérant le rythme cardiaque les
artères sont assouplis le sang est
fluidifié et la pression artérielle
diminuée résultat un risque d'AVC réduit
de 25%
le sport améliore aussi le métabolisme
il augmente la consommation de glucides
et de lipides on développe donc moins de
maladies métaboliques faire de
l'exercice réduit par exemple de 58%, le
risque de développer un diabète de type
2 le système nerveux lui aussi en
profite faire du sport peut ralentir
l'apparition de certaines maladies
neurodégénératives comme la maladie
d'Alzheimer de plus il a été prouvé que
le sport était un antidépresseur naturel
l'activité physique a également un effet
protecteur contre les cancers en
limitant le taux de certaines hormones
ou facteurs de croissance ainsi il y
aurait 25 à 30% de risque en moins de
développer un cancer du sein ou du côlon
en pratiquant une activité sportive
régulière le sport agit donc comme un
véritable médicament d'ailleurs selon
l'OMS 5 millions de décès par an
pourrait être évité si la population
mondiale était plus active
[Musique]
Martin Fourcade vous êtes un encore un
sportif de très très haut niveau vous
avez en face de vous quelqu'un qui
n'arrive pas à se mettre au sport
qu'est-ce que vous lui dites pour le
motiver c'est déjà de commencer avant de
faire du sport c'est de commencer par
une activité physique donc ça veut dire
que de remplacer dans son quotidien tout
ce qui est on va dire mobilité inutile
prendre le métro pour faire deux sorties
par le fait de se déplacer à pied ce que
je fais avec mes enfants j'habite à 2 km
de l'école et on y va à pied tous les
matins
avec les enfants pas mal mais c'est
aussi un moment en fait qui est agréable
de transition entre le stress du matin
pour préparer et le moment où on va à
l'école donc c'est déjà un premier pas
vers l'activité physique ensuite c'est
de trouver une activité qui est certes
ludique et dans laquelle on va prendre
du plaisir mais c'est aussi considérer
que le sport est quelque chose de
nécessaire
et qui a un effort à considérer et qu'on
peut pas s'en passer de la même manière
qu'on dort tous les soirs on doit
pratiquer du sport presque tous les
jours en tout cas il y a des
professionnels effectivement qui
essayent de donner cette motivation à
ceux qui ont absolument besoin de faire
de l'exercice physique et qu'il n'y
arrive pas à le puiser en elle-même
regardez ce reportage d'Alexia le Pérou
[Musique]
contrairement aux apparences cet endroit
est plus proche du cabinet médical que
de la salle de sport
le suivi il est individualisé
personnalisé pour rendre le sport aussi
agréable que possible
[Musique]
32 séances pour une remise en forme
générale avec un objectif donné envie de
ne jamais arrêter de chances
il dure à peu près 48 heures donc c'est
quelque chose que l'on doit on doit
faire régulièrement pendant la semaine
donc et du coup pendant toute la vie
c'est le principe de l'adaptation au
niveau physiologique donc on donne on
stimule l'accord pour qu'il se renforce
pour qu'il en 1950 physique si on
abandonne
après on reste
c'est des adaptes et il perd les
capacités la condition physique parce
qu'il y a il y en a plus besoin
cette patiente malade chronique arrive
bientôt à la fin de son programme pour
elle c'est décidé les cours de sport
continuent car elle en ressent le
bénéfice
j'avais vraiment baissé quoi et je me
suis porté plus mais j'ai commencé à
ressentir des bienfaits assez rapidement
et là maintenant je peux aller
du deuxième sous-sol au quatrième étage
sans ascenseur sans je commence à sentir
juste dans les dernières marches quoi
elle évidence le sport serait donc un
bon médicament à condition d'être
régulier comme le montre ce test au
laboratoire du centre
[Musique]
allez allez
finalement le sport fonctionne comme
beaucoup de traitement
l'arrêter n'est pas recommandé exemple
avec ce patient atteint d'un covid long
suivi depuis plusieurs mois il pratique
le sport mais de manière irrégulière
aujourd'hui on va chercher à avoir une
PMA donc la puissance maximale aérobie
donc c'est le la puissance maximale que
Jean-François peut développer en
utilisant comme ressources principales
l'oxygène
ok on continue de tourner genre tourner
jambe ton les jambes il y a plus de
résistance allez tourne les jambes
tourne les jambes tournent les jambes
lui aussi a bénéficié du programme de 32
séances de sport il est désormais suivi
pendant 5 ans pour faire le point sur
ses performances et sur sa motivation
dans le cadre d'une étude menée par ce
centre ces âmes
aujourd'hui c'est son troisième bilan et
surprises avant de commencer ces âmes tu
avais validé 210
après sésame tu avais validé 225 et là
tu es pile poil entre les deux une
petite baisse de performance qui
s'explique facilement un manque
d'activité physique depuis quelques mois
on va se mettre juste là ce genre
d'études le démontre scientifiquement
l'activité physique doit être régulière
pour être efficace le tout est de
trouver de la motivation
ok donc du coup sur cette dernière année
toi comment ça s'est déroulée au niveau
de l'activité physique j'aimerais
pouvoir en faire plus clairement surtout
j'aimerais pouvoir en faire de manière
régulière maintenant l'emploi du temps
ne le permet pas
donc
c'est souvent la raison pour laquelle
j'en fais pas assez on va parler de
comment ça se passe dans la vie dans la
vie privée dans la vie professionnelle
on va essayer de voir quel problématique
ils peuvent rencontrer quels outils on
peut leur donner pour les aider
favoriser la régularité c'est donc
rendre la prescription du sport plus
efficace
pour le médecin qui dirige l'étude il
faut pour que le sport soit un bon
médicament trouver comment motiver les
patients à continuer sur le long terme
on sait que l'activité physique c'est
bon pour la santé la clé ça va être
d'identifier les éléments de motivation
au fur et à mesure du temps qui passe
qu'on pourra surtout utiliser en amont
en fonction du profit des personnes donc
on doit identifier ce profil des
personnes chacun a des contraintes
particulières des freins mais aussi des
leviers qui vont être utiles en fait
d'identifier pour les actionner et
maintenir cette motivation c'est levier
ça peut être simplement de pouvoir
peut-être ne pas trop en demander
peut-être aussi davantage écouter faire
aussi émerger ce que la personne veut
c'est à dire que le meilleur moteur
c'est ce qu'on appelle la motivation
intrinsèque ce qui vient de la personne
d'après la plupart des études
scientifiques la régularité compte plus
que la quantité aussi 30 minutes
d'activité par jour suffirait pour être
en bonne santé mais ceci tous les jours
[Musique]
Martin Fourcade vous disiez tout à
l'heure il faut aussi trouver le sport
qu'on a envie de pratiquer en fait le
sport c'est tellement varié c'est
tellement divers que c'est ridicule de
vouloir se forcer à faire de la course à
pied alors qu'on va trouver finalement
son bonheur en pratiquant une autre
discipline sportive donc je pense qu'il
y a assez de choix et de diversité pour
pouvoir trouver un mode d'activité
physique et un sport qui nous convient
des sports qu'on peut pratiquer le plus
longtemps possible dans sa vie c'est
quoi le vélo il y a le vélo qui est
parce qu'il est très peu traumatisant il
y a pas d'impact la course à pied un
sport qui va générer des impacts
quotidiens et donc qui peut créer des
douleurs
musculaires ou genou on est porté sur le
vélo effectivement
du sport qu'on peut pratiquer tout en
douceur très tard et j'habite j'ai la
chance d'habiter la belle région
d'Annecy et tous les jours il y a une
mamie qui qui va se baigner dans le lac
et que je croise quotidiennement sur le
vélo ou à pied on voyait aussi dans le
reportage l'importance de la régularité
faire du sport de temps en temps ça
suffit pas non ça suffit pas et c'est
aussi c'est mieux que rien bien sûr on
parlait tout à l'heure de motivation et
de et d'emprunt le fait de ne pas
pratiquer une activité régulière fait
qu'à chaque fois on se retrouve au pied
de la montagne et du coup c'est dur de
réenclencher cette dynamique finalement
l'activité physique régulière permet de
conserver un niveau de pratique
auquel on va on va prendre du plaisir
plus facilement et on va sortir
finalement la tête de l'eau si je peux
dire plus facilement une chose que l'on
a bien compris c'est la sédentarité
notamment celle des enfants qui sont
scotchés à la maison dans les écrans etc
etc l'importance de l'éducation pour le
sport chez les enfants très jeunes je
vous propose qu'on regarde leur portage
avec ça le permet on se retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
à vos marques
les enfants court-il moins vite qu'avant
nous avons fait le test dans ce club
d'athlétisme en faisant courir 800
mètres à une vingtaine d'enfants
résultats ils mettent en moyenne 4
minutes 17
Colette qui dirige le club a fait de
l'athlétisme toute sa vie dans les
années 70 7 moyenne était de 3 minutes
en gros en moyenne ils ont perdu une
minute sur 800 mètres c'est à dire une
capacité aérobie qui a baissé de 2 km/h
voilà il y a 20 ans puisqu'on a gardé
des statistiques et performances du
groupe correspondait à peu près aux
performances des meilleurs d'aujourd'hui
c'est pas grave respire respire
on la voit cette baisse de performance
et elle est plus importante en fait que
celle que je viens de vous dire parce
que les enfants qui sont là sont des
enfants certains ils sont dans le club
depuis très longtemps alors que nous
avons des enfants dans les collèges
quand on organise avec les collèges des
courses qui sont même pas capables de
courir 250 mètres c'est à dire qui
s'arrêtent au bout de 150 mètres ils
sont épuisés au bout de 250 mètres
cette baisse de performance se retrouve
à l'échelle mondiale c'est ce que
montrait cette étude australienne de
2016 selon les chercheurs les enfants
avaient perdu chaque décennie 5% de leur
capacité cardiovasculaires depuis les
années 70
cette étude a été reprise par de
nombreux médecins inquiet face à ces
résultats comme le professeur François
carré pour lui la baisse de performance
cache un risque sanitaire
on peut parler de bombes à retardement
sanitaire puisque ça concerne des
enfants
dont on pense qu'ils sont en bonne santé
les chiffres nous montrent que c'est
faux puisque leur capacité physique
baisse excès dans 20 ans qui vont avoir
ou qui risque d'avoir un problème pour
leur santé on voit apparaître
aujourd'hui dans notre consultation des
adolescents qui ont diabétiques de type
2 quand j'étais jeune médecin le diabète
de type 2 c'était l'homme de 40 ans
un risque d'autant plus grand
qu'aujourd'hui
66% des adolescents ne respectent pas
les recommandations de l'OMS en termes
d'activité physique une fois adulte ce
chiffre monte à 95%
pour le médecin il faut donc tout
réapprendre
un enfant qui ne bouge pas sur un adulte
qui ne bougera pas après un enfant qui
bouge à tendance à plus bouger quand il
sera adulte à lui de continuer à garder
ses bonnes habitudes par contre c'est
sûr toutes les études montrent les
adultes comptent questionnent qui ne
marchent pas me dis je n'ai jamais fait
de sport dans mon enfance je n'ai jamais
fait d'activité physique pour changer
les comportements la solution pourrait
venir de l'école
depuis la rentrée c'est désormais au
programme les enfants de primaire
doivent réaliser 30 minutes d'activité
physique par jour cette école avait pris
les devants et expérimenter la mesure
depuis déjà deux ans
la première difficulté pour
l'enseignante quelle est ses 30 minutes
dans son programme alors elle a dû
adapter ses cours
comme ce matin avec le cours d'anglais
qui a lieu en mouvement
je me suis vite rendu compte que je
pouvais pas faire
tout le temps 15 minutes 20 minutes
d'activité physique en plus de mon
planning quotidien donc ça c'était une
réelle difficulté et c'est pour ça du
coup que j'ai décidé de faire ce côté
[Musique]
transdisciplinarité et
par rapport au programme par rapport au
temps et que j'ai décidé de le coupler
avec une autre une autre matière
est-ce que ça vous a réveillé est-ce que
vous sentez en forme pour affronter
cette journée est-ce que ça vous a
réchauffé quand on remonte d'une séance
comme ça en général je les sens beaucoup
plus
disponible pour pour faire la suite du
travail effectivement être assis toute
la journée c'est sûr que à la fin on
voit bien on voit bien qu'ils sont pas
capables de se tenir assis correctement
toute une journée donc ils ont besoin de
ces moments là où ils font d'autres
activités ou alors ils ont besoin aussi
de travailler dans autrement que assise
sur sur une chaise aujourd'hui la mesure
des 30 minutes d'activité par jour reste
encore inégalement appliquée dans les
établissements que ce soit par manque de
temps ou d'équipement
[Musique]
il est passionnant ce reportage parce
qu'on voit toutes toutes les tous les
bienfaits allant du sport pour les
enfants effectivement y compris pour
travailler mieux à l'école c'est facile
de mettre ses enfants devant la télé
c'est plus difficile de les motiver à
sortir de les motiver à prendre un vélo
de les motiver à aller marcher en forêt
dans un parc
de pratiquer une activité voilà il y a
quelque chose de de passif et finalement
c'est aussi un effort au quotidien pour
les parents dans une dans une vie ou
d'un des emplois du temps tous bien
chargés il faut se forcer à prendre ces
moments-là aussi pour ses enfants les
paroles du médecin résonnent fort parce
qu'un enfant qui pratique et en tout cas
moi ça a été mon cas tout mon enfance et
un adulte qui va avoir envie de
pratiquer et pour lequel finalement ce
sera un réflexe c'est plus un effort un
programme qui a été donné à l'éducation
nationale c'est 30 minutes par jour
c'est assez on en fait assez en France
on n'a pas une culture sportive
tellement France non par rapport à des
pays que vous connaissez les pays qui
ont une culture sportive qui est
beaucoup plus ancrée notamment à l'école
ça a été un pendant de longues années
quelle est la place du sport à l'école
je crois qu'aujourd'hui avec les jeux
Paris de Paris 2024 et vous parlez des
30 minutes de sport à l'école qui sont
un programme qui est initié par les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de Paris
2024 on va dans la bonne voie moi je
vois mais justement mes enfants je leur
demande ce qu'elles font et en tout cas
même si c'est inégalement réparti
inégalement
pratiqué pour l'instant c'est une
dynamique qui se met en place et ça doit
faire partie des héritages des jeux de
paris 2024 donner une place au sport
plus importante dans notre société et
surtout à l'école vous êtes engagé dans
les CIO on a vu tout à l'heure dans
votre portrait ça va changer quelque
chose les JO de voir les JO à Paris vous
pensez dans la place qu'on accorde au
sport en France alors je crois que ça
change déjà quelque chose on parle des
30 minutes de sport à l'école c'est un
projet un programme qui ne se serait
jamais mis en place si on n'avait pas eu
les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques en
France en 2024 c'est une nation qui va
plus regarder le sport c'est des médias
qui tournent de plus en plus par
programme vers le sport c'est toute une
dynamique qui se met en place avec des
partenaires qui vont commencer à
communiquer aussi autour du sport de
Paris 2024 et des valeurs de l'olympisme
alors il y a un autre levier c'est le
sport sur ordonnance alors ça existe on
a d'ailleurs déjà parlé dans cet état de
santé on a demandé à un député François
Cormier bouligeon qui est un député
renaissance du Cher s'il était favorable
lui à ce qu'on rembourse on prenne en
charge la puissance publique à 100%
le sport le sport sur ordonnance
remboursé il est pour ou pas on l'écoute
[Musique]
il faut que ce soit encadré parce que il
faut que il n'y ait pas de
contre-indication à la pratique d'un
sport ou d'une activité physique et il
faut que les intervenants soient
totalement formés universitairement pour
faire ses activités donc il faut
l'encadrer mais à partir du moment où
nous avons des éducateurs physiques qui
sont formés et à partir du moment où
nous avons des prescriptions très
claires alors oui moi je suis pour que
le rembourse des séances d'activité
parce que
ne traiter qu'en curatif coûte beaucoup
plus cher que favoriser la prévention
mais j'ai vu que le ministre de la Santé
est très attaché à la question de la
prévention y compris par le sport donc
j'ai bon espoir que dans ce quinquennat
nous trouverons des bonnes solutions
[Musique]
Martin Fourcade donc on parle bien
évidemment du remboursement du sport
d'une activité sportive dans le cadre de
maladies chroniques en particulier
est-ce que pour vous
c'est indispensable que ce soit
remboursé peut-être des temps de
dispositif d'ailleurs c'est une super
initiative sur ce public particulier sur
les gens qui sont malades chroniques qui
sont qui ont des besoins
d'accompagnement et qui ont besoin que
ce soit finalement pris en charge dans
leur cursus médical c'est pas quelque
chose qui est transposable à l'ensemble
de la population on parle beaucoup du
vieillissement il y a une vraie
problématique vieillir bien vieillir
mieux parce qu'on vit de plus en plus
longtemps ça c'est quand même aussi je
veux dire un levier important pour faire
du sport c'est de retarder le plus
possible
ces moments où on perd possession de
soi-même et puis de continuer à
pratiquer ce que je pense que c'est un
lien aussi avec l'extérieur si on arrive
à marcher à sortir faire le tour du
quartier on parle plus de sport à cette
vie on parle de justement on en parlait
au début de l'activité physique mais
le grand-père de ma compagne à 100 un an
et tous les jours il va faire sa marche
d'une demi-heure et je trouve ça assez
remarquable et je pense qu'il y a le
fait qu'il descend un an et qui marche
et remarquable et peut-être que c'est
parce qu'il marche qu'il est aussi à cet
âge là en mode santé et qui donc voilà
je pense que c'est un cercle vertueux
quelle est la cause quel est l'effet
j'ai commencé l'émission en disant en
posant sur la table que on avait tous
compris que le sport c'était bien
c'était bon pour la santé est-ce que
vous pensez qu'on l'a suffisamment bien
compris vraiment le lien entre santé
forme physique vieillissement prévention
qui est très importante je pense qu'on
l'a compris que c'est quelque chose qui
est dans le le discours général ensuite
c'est peut-être quelque chose qui en
2022 doit être encore plus renforcé
on a tous des publicités avec manger
cinq fruits et légumes par jour on a
moins les même avec la pratique du sport
ce serait bien de faire plus de pub je
pense que c'est un message qui doit être
qui doit être porté aussi dans une
société où on a beaucoup plus tendance à
se tourner vers les écrans donc oui je
crois que c'est nécessaire aussi de
faire attention à ça et de d'aller plus
loin dans l'attention qu'on porte sur
ces messages là merci beaucoup Martin
Fourcade de notre invité dans les états
de santé merci de nous avoir suivis à
très vite sur la chaîne parlementaire
[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance vous
a présenté état de santé
[Musique]